dude you know who's the baddest tenors
percentage of food truck with him Jorge
Masvidal
man I'm so jealous I I just he's such a
badass I'd love to meet that guy nice
don't hurry up and get out here for
Bryan come look at his hair he's here
Street Jesus
yeah man came up in a very cushy way
lots of money lots of presents at
Christmas he's an introvert man yeah
introvert just wants to be shouldn't be
kind of on his own you know he's paid
his dues cat he's got a kid that dick
career in the world what yeah he's got
the most authentic no wife two kids no
wife okay I didn't know that I told my
Orie
what do miami best-looking women I've
ever seen my life feels oh yeah yeah
know what you seeing us oh yeah yeah all
right she's not busting many nuts no no
no girls don't like a champion like that
a badass straight a bad a handsome guy
with that hair it was as good as it gets
it hit what he does has a plant open out
the car a little cameo back there now
makes sense for he's in the car shop
because I see the old man that color
that rear color
we're not talk about the Prius right
there he's talking right there yeah I'm
yeah I'm talking about the Miami blue
yeah what food truck did you guys you
know what for him we didn't do a food
truck you want really good sushi and
we're kind of looking around for food
trucks so we had really good sushi
brought in we had a waiter oh so he
didn't know so during the middle
conversation I was like dude already
next bite and then this weight came out
with this really good yeah that's a very
few huh I was because you're the baddest
[ __ ] on planet I didn't do a
food truck I brought real sushi to you I
wait Hans or whatever [ __ ] you thought
and then like this guy no tuxedo came
out brother very funny yeah now does he
um is he training right now or is he
taking it easy
uh he's out here for stem cells oh wow
jeez yeah
great dude just like solid yes also
regular yeah I'm almost a mom mostly
guys are man but he's just I mean such a
sweet person yeah that's the kind soul
has he ever so style been there like
this these guys man there's like they're
just so authentic and genuine can't help
but love them man you just
well my feeling is that they're both
they're actually characters they're
colorful characters like you love to
wash them they know how to turn around
that they they know how to be showman
but part of the way they're showman is
that they're really authentic like they
back up what they say but but with
horath know things playing and none of
it's like he doesn't want to do
interviews he doesn't want to do that
stuff like when bannard nacre them talk
[ __ ] like it's for him it's personal
yes so he's not doing anything like that
he doesn't think of anything
preconceived like honor chill right he
just he doesn't want to be in the
spotlight
yeah he wants a lot of money and the
best fights yeah that's like once who is
stopping a to like he doesn't want these
super fights he doesn't want this you
know yeah like that that whole dancing
and that left him he would do that
whether it was at Marvel Arena in front
of a hundred thousand people or or he
was fighting in a backyard he'd be doing
those same will he fight at 55 over 70
Maz Vidal floats between but he'll fight
at 70 hue 50 fights gotta be hard for
him to make 25 stuff he's done it but he
would do it before it could be he would
do it for kabhi who free could be have
you saw that could be problem yeah the
hora is in a great position because this
was our conversation I don't know when
they release it but it was like like
he's bigger than the belt like he's a
bigger name than both the guys fighting
for the title yeah so he doesn't really
care so he wants Nick Diaz or which Nick
wants him or he once got McGregor he's a
I don't care about the belt like I I'm
bigger like he's right he's bigger than
the belt what the bell icon is kind of
intriguing to me but I mean Conor at
this point but because Conor's boxing is
really good his striking and I feel like
they'd they'd box it out yeah however
Jorge would also kick Conor in his legs
in his body home can cake too though
yeah not like Jorge not that not with
that like Vegas kicker with with Nate
Diaz he was just laying to those ribs
though you know that that's front kick
beside you know what I mean so and he'll
and although I don't like to do conifers
Jorge next yeah Hunter's bright colors
gonna fight cowboy in January
and what he is kind of Jorge want that's
the plan that's what they want and what
Jorge wants is to be on the co-main
event against Nick Diaz and I know Nick
wants to fight and they've reached out
to his team so that'd be January 18 yeah
Nick ts it's a great conversation though
he was fantastic can't help but love the
guy he's got to go correct me if I'm
wrong though with smun is ultimately
they never did anything that's what was
our conversation I think he'll do
anything
yeah well he would fight for the 55
title no 70 he'd stay at 70 so yeah he
don't know your father's advice could be
yeah fight easy 70 welterweight right
yeah what's interesting cuz loose money
and Colby are third and fourth choices
Ryan Wow he's he have photo title I'm
bigger than the title which he's way
more famous than both guys he's right
yeah he's striking one problem he sucked
up and off a bigger win he's never
really lost he's lost controversial
decisions yeah like who has he actually
been actually I was finished never done
the FC that's yeah that's like Nick Diaz
in his prime Nick never was really put
down he got he got put down by Paul
Daley and then came back and knocked
Paul Daley out with the same well they
got finished by Josh Thompson Nate Nate
no yeah but Nick I'm told Nick nothing
different Nick was always like just
phenomenal that way you can even what
Nick about five years yeah fought who
was his last fight him since over that
was so weird what he's doing yeah yeah
it's gonna be light though I'm intrigued
by that fight actually I bet it happens
really that it happens yeah tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]